[Music]
the entire film is you making these
amazing amazing dishes and these amazing
sandwiches and you watch the movie and
you just salivate yeah it was it's a
it's been called food porn which I
proudly embrace that term right and I
love I love cooking I've learned to cook
a lot I know you cook a lot quite the
barbecue artists yourself oh well maybe
I love shy Andy Jean yeah a lot of
training and I and I love movies like
big night like you said an eat drink man
woman and jiro Dreams of Sushi and I
figured if I did I could do a movie
about a chef if I really learn how to
cook and photograph it right it could be
I know I love watching films like that
so it was really fun to learn and train
and to make a movie like this so you
trained and you took it very seriously
and you can now make this food I I was
there on the set making and I had Roy
Choi a chef who has started the Kogi
barbecue truck
Korean barbecue truck but he's also a
classically trained chef and I shadowed
him and he sent me to culinary school
and I worked in his kitchens so I got to
the point where I could look like I knew
what I was doing and now I still love
doing it and I still I do it at home I
just got my third smoker in the backyard
now I'm putting a commercial kitchen in
to my weight you're turning your kitchen
into a commercial kitchen I'm out all
the I'm putting stainless steel in and
it looks like a kitchen from a
restaurant because I've really grown to
appreciate that it's a it's a good
midlife crisis hobby for a guy my
stature safer than some other ones yeah
yeah I bought Arabian horses I do yeah
I'm trying to ride them and I lost all
my money and yeah yeah it's terrible
they ran away ran away you could smoke
them too yeah
delicious I had one and it was delicious
now I'm gonna get some people riding in
how dare you okay you wrote and directed
this yum and I knew that you wrote and
directed it before I even saw the
credits because I'm watching the movie
and I realized that you cast Sofia
Vergara yes as your ex-wife and Scarlett
Johansson as your girlfriend yes and I
thought this man is a genius
and then you fill the whole set with
amazing food yes exactly
well I there's no furious at you it's
just kudos yeah you had to show how good
of a cook this guy was so that's the
only way I could do it is by showing
that if these women eat this food and
retract it to me you know the food must
taste pretty good
okay all right that's fair yeah I
brought some I brought a little bit of
brisket I just smoked yesterday because
I know you guys are aficionados if you'd
like to try a little bit this is my my
new my new hobby is uh his smoke hey
here's what you carry meat around in a
bag yeah this is what's known as a dime
bag of brisket this is just a little
just a little tail yeah and this one
freeze right it's just to get your hooks
the first one's always free we go and
then we got to pay that's a nice bark by
the way everybody get a shot of that in
there get a camera
oh here we go [ __ ] do and let me just
get a shot of this this is smoked
brisket right here yes that's gorgeous
look at that camera three right there my
hand there it is look at the marbling
it's like sushi so you made this I did
this it took about 14 hours last night
all for you that's fantastic it's real
you like it yeah wonderful now I'm
getting really healthy it's no carbs I
there's no fat in here right now here
Seth Rogen is is quite the brisket
smoker himself watch that
and I notice on Twitter he tweets a lot
about his brain I see is we both tweet
and Instagram are briskets so I'd like
to try his brisket next time you have
him on let me know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so next time you have them on let me
know I'll come by with some more brisket
and we could you know I just love I love
the idea that your calling card is meat
that you carry on you yes
you bring meat with you I do you're like
I cooked up something people usually
don't do that with meat I guess because
you know it's like hey I made some Mayo
a couple of days ago I got it right here
in my pocket I know you're having by a
man number on it like a business card
yeah it's a you know like I said I'm I'm
in my 40s this is this is all I have
left
really but but I did I'm so glad you
like the film and the cast is also great
Robert Downey jr. is in there as well
and as you said Scarlett Johansson Sofia
Vergara like with amo is quite funny in
the movie he killed it yeah yeah I
really like him so and I want to thank
everybody who's watching because this
thing just started off in two cities and
without a billboard or anything just
word of mouth and Twitter it's now in
1,300 screens this weekend because it
the word spread so thank you
[Applause]
you